[موسيقى]
تغيير الدستور في اي بلد من البلدان ليس
مهما يمكن تغيير الدستور لكن المهم السبب
الذي من اجله يتم تغيير الدستور في دراسه
مهمه عملتها كليه القانون بجامعه شيكاغو
الامريكيه الدراسه عملت مسح شامل لكل تثير
العالم من سنه الف وسبعمائه وتسعه وثمانين
حتى 2009 وخلصت الى نتائج مهمه منها
المتوسط عمر الدساتير في العالم على مدار
ال اكثر من ستين سنه اللي هي عمر الدراسه
سبعطاشر سنه متوسط عمر الدستور وانه
الواضح انه طول عمره الدساتير مرتبط
بالاستقرار السياسي علشان كده اوروبا
الغربيه متوسط عمر الدساتير فيه اثنين
وثلاثين سنه والفتره التي تنزل التي
تسعطاشر سنه في الدول الاسير وبتنزل الى
اثناشر سنه واربع شهور في دول امريكا
اللاتينيه
وعشر سنين وشهرين في دول افريقيا الاقل
استقرارا على مستوى العالم دراسه كمان
بتقول انه خمسين في المائه من دساتير
العالم لا يكمل عامه و 18 وانه ال ال اكثر
من كده انه كمان الدول المتقدمه فيها
اتجاهين ممكن تجد دوله متقدمه وعندها
ديمقراطيه ومع ذلك لا يتم لكن لا يتم فيها
تغيير الدستور او دوله ديمقراطيه ولكن يتم
فيها تغيير الدستور بشكل سريع المثال على
الدول الديمقراطيه التي لا يتم فيها تغيير
الدستور الى الولايات المتحده اللي منذ
سنه الف وسبعمائه وتسعه وثمانين لم يتغير
دستورها ابدا ولكن ادخلت على التعديلات
وعدد التعديلات سبعه وعشرين تعديل يعني
تغيرات محدوده جدا بالنسبه لدوله وضع
الدستور ها من اكثر من مائتين خمسه وعشرين
سنه في المقابل يضرب المثل بفرنسا في
تغيير الدساتير لانها غير دستورها بالكامل
15 مره منذ قيام الثوره الفرنسيه سنه الف
وسبعمائه تسعه وثمانين ايضا وضعت دستورها
الاول بعدها بسنتين ثلاثه واحد وتسعين الف
وسبعمائه وواحد وتسعين وتم تغيير الدستور
بعد اداء 15 مره كان اخرهم ثلاثه ثمانيه
وخمسين والدستور الحالي تم اجراء
تعديلات عليه 17 مره يعني ممكن تبقى دوله
ديمقراطيه يحصل فيها تغيير كبير للدستور
طيب كويس لكن المحكمه مره ثانيه السبب اذا
كان السبب قوي فلا باس ناخذ مثال على سبب
قوي استوجب تغيير الدستور مثلا جنوب
افريقيا في الوقت الحالي هناك مطالبات او
جاري اعداد ال يعني المناخ لتغيير الدستور
لانه ال الدوله والشعب راى انه لا بد من
اعاده توزيع الاراضي انه موجوده هذه
الاراضي كاحد نتائج حكم الاقليه البيضاء
والحكومات العنصريه او النظام العنصري
اللي كان موجود في الدوله جنوب افريقيا
بمقتضاه البيض كانوا بيفتكروا الاقليه
البيضاء ب تحتكر الغالبيه العظمى من
الاراضي وبالتالي الثروات وبالتالي ما فيش
اي عداله في توزيع الثروه في البلد الان
الشعب والحكومه انه حان الوقت لاعاده
النظر في هذا الخلل الكبير ولابد من
انتزاع الاراضي من الاقليه البيضاء دون
اعطاء هم تعويض بعد ما يترك لهم الحد
الادنى يعني عمليه تامين او انتزعت زي ما
حصل في بلدان عربيه كثيره المساله تادي
تعديل في الدستور ولذلك يجري تعديل
الدستور امر حتمي هذا امر مهم لانه يؤدي
الى تغيير كبير في المجتمع و لسبب مصري
لكن في تسير ب يتم تغييرها
بالماس لشخص معين حتى يظل في السلطه ال او
الامثله في العالم العربي كثيره جدا وكلنا
نذكر ان في سنه الفين
بعد وفاه الرئيس السوري حافظ الاسد تم
بتعديل الدستور
السوري علشان
الحد الادنى لعمر الرئيس اللي ممكن يترشح
للرئاسه من اربعين لاربعه وثلاثين علشان
يناسب الدكتور بشار الاسد الرئيس الحالي
في سوريا وتم الموافقه على هذه التعديلات
في جلسه استمرت ثلاثه دقائق
التعديلات المصريه اللي جاريه الان واللي
اقرها البرلمان باغلبيه كبيره جدا غيري
الان صيغتها يعني يعني في طور الاعداد
بتنتمي الى النوع الثاني من التعديلات
اللي هي المقصود بها الهدف الاساسي من هذه
التعديلات هو ال اتاحه الفرصه للرئيس
الحالي عبد الفتاح السيسى الى المقاومه
السلطه لسنوات اخرى قادمه سنوات اطول بين
سنه اثنين وعشرين هو مدته بتخلص سنه اثنين
وعشرين الولايه الثانيه اربع سنوات اربع
سنوات لم يمكنوا من البقاء من التعديلات
الموجوده لنا شر سنه بعد انتهاء ولايته
الثانيه سنه اثنين وعشرين انا استطيع ان
ارسل ببساطه انه فيه ثلاث توجهات داخل مصر
اتجاه هذه الرغبه او تجاه التعديلات
المعتزله
يؤيد التغيير الدستوري وفريق يعارض اجراء
التغيير الدستوري وفريق غير مكترث وغير
مؤتمر الفريق اللي عاوز او الفريق اللي
يؤيد التغيرات الدستوريه منطقه كالاتي
انه الرئيس الحالي نجح في انه يعمل عدد
ضخمه جدا من المشروعات وان المشروع دي مش
مشروعات صغيره يعني محطه ميه هنا ولا محطه
تصرف هناك في مشروعات ممتده من اقصى
الشمال لاقصى الجنوب مشروعات البنيه
التحتيه في كل مكان تهربها
صرف صحي اربعطاشر مدينه جديده من عاصمه
جديده
محور قناه السويس
اعاده النظر في التعليم في التامين الصحي
لديه رغبه كبيره في اعاده النظر في كثير
من المؤسسات تحديث القوات المسلحه امور
كثيره يعددها مؤيده الرئيس انهم ما شايفين
انه الرجل يجب ان يبقى حتى يكمل ما بدا
وبالتالي ايه المانع يعني انه يتم تعديل
الدستور خصوصا من اربع سنوات دي فتره اولا
وانه في الدول حتى الدول الديمقراطيه
بتسمح بخمس سنين وست سنين وما فيش مشكله
القصه وانه الحديث عن اربع سنوات ده حتى
في الولايات المتحده يعني ظروفها الولايات
المتحده دوله فدراليه ومن التنميه
والاعمار مرتبط بال رئيس الدوله
الفيدراليه لكن كل ولايه تعتني بشؤون
الفريق المعارض له وجهه نظر اخرى ويعارض
التعديلات الدستوريه لاحد سببين السبب
منهم ان فريق من المعارضين هو معارض
الرئيس نفسه وغير مقتنع ب انجازاته شايف
انه الحديث عن انجازات الرئيس مبالغ فيها
كثيرا وانه حتى لو كان عنده انجازات فهو
عنده خلل كبير في عدد من الامور فيما
يتعلق على المستوى الاقتصادي انه مع
المشروعات الكبيره اللي بيعملها في دين
عام متزايد دين داخلي و دين خارجي قد نعم
الامر الثاني انه في خلق مناخ الحريات
العامه وان هذا الخنق مع اه صعب تستمر
الحياه لا اقتصاديه ولا سياسيا
الامر ال
الداء فيما يتعلق بال معارضين وبالتالي هم
مش عم بيصير انه الرئيس يستمر
لانهم مش مقتنعين بالسياسات ولا بان في
فريق يؤيد الرئيس لكن يعارض تغيير الدستور
من
منطق انه مهما كانت انجازات الرئيس يجب ان
نقول له شكرا وكافه احتراما للدستور لانه
تغيير الدستور عدنا الى المربع رقم واحد
نفس الماساه اللي حصلت في اه ايام الرئيس
السادات ونفس الماساه اللي حصلت ايام
الرئيس مبارك تغيير الدستور الى مجرد خدمه
الرئيس الحالي للابقاء عليه في السلطه
لاطول فتره ممكنه او حتى للسماح بتوريث
السلطه كما فسرت التعديلات ايام الرئيس
مبارك وبالتالي هذا خطا كبير يترتب عليه
فوضى ويترتب عليه تيار كبير اللي هو
بالتيار الثالث اللي هو ال غير مكترث
المواطن الذي يشعر انه لا قيمه
للاستفتاءات ولا قيمه للانتخابات لانه
الحكومه غالبه على امرها وتنفذ اللى هى
عاوزاه ما فيش داعي المساله دي لا تعنينا
ويحصل عمليه العزال ويحصل عمليه تقوقعوا
حصل ان البلد بلدنا ويحصل عمليه التكلف
ثاني لسنوات الازمه اللي كانت موجوده ايام
الرئيس
الاطراف الثلاثه اللي هي الاتجاهات
الثلاثه اللي موجوده بالنسبه لكل التعديل
الدستوري الحقيقه انه انا قلت راي فيما
يتعلق اعاده ما بقولش راي انا برصد الاراء
المختلفه لكن فيما يتعلق بالتعديل
الدستوري وايضا يعني لانه فيه البعض الطلب
انه انا اوضح اكثر فانا قلت راي في حلقه
الدول العربيه على صفيح ساخن قلت انه
جمهوريه مصر العربيه
سوف تواجه باحدى ازمتين بالحلول عام اثنين
وعشرين ازمه اذا التزم الرئيس الحالي
بالدستور وترك السلطه في سنه اثنين ال
ازمه ناتجه عن انه الفضاء العام انه ما
فيش عندنا مؤسسات وانزيم الرئيس اكثر من
مره قبل ان يتوقف على استخدام الكلمه انه
مصر بشركه دوله المؤسسات ضعيفه جدا
البرلمان الاحزاب ما عندناش احزاب
المعارضه ما عندناش مؤسسات وبالتالي اذا
الرئيس ترك السلطه النهار ده يبقى عندنا
مشكله من يحل محله
وانه من يحل محل وفي النهايه ينتهي بنا
الامر الى ان
يتولى السلطه هو اللي سوف تدعم اهم وابواب
مؤسسه في مصر وهي القوات المسلحه وهي يكون
دور بقيه المؤسسات اللي هي يجمل صوره
المرشح القادم وخصوصا للاعلام تقنع الناس
وبالتالي هو الرئيس القادم يعني بدها تكون
ازمه ان ان تجد البديل بسهوله لان المجتمع
مش ما فيش في حياه في السياسه قنوات
السياسه كافه جدا
مده امر غريب لبلد يعني عاش فورتين
متتابعتين خمسه وعشرين يناير واه ثلاثين
الامر الثاني انه ال ال اه انه اه طبعا
بالازمه الاولانيه الازمه الاكبر منها ان
الرئيس يقبل او اه يحصل عمليه تغيير
للدستور لانه اذا حصل عمليه تغيير الدستور
قلت الحضارات وكل ما نعيد اذكركم بالناس
الى رفضها تغيير الدستور لانه دا يعني
دور لكلمه القانون او مشاهد واربعه
تعميق لفتره اهدار القانون اللي موجوده في
مصر من سنوات لانه مش مهم الدستور
الدستوري تعيين ويمكن خرقه للقوانين ت
تعمل و يمكن تجاوزها والتغلب عليها و يساء
تفسيرها المهمه ان رغبت السلطه تنفذ ودي
مساله خطيره جدا مش خطيره من قبيل الانشاء
يعني انه احترام الدستور في كلمه كان قبيل
يعني كل شيء لكن اذا ترتب عليها
مشاكل كبيره جدا اقتصاديه وسياسيه
واضحه
انا اقول لحضراتكم على مثال
صديق فرنسي لينا يحكي قصه النجاح حضر الى
مصر وبعدين ندخل في منازعات حصل على احكام
قضائيه بحقه في الحصول على قطاع ارض ومصنع
من شركاء اللي اختلف معهم او اللي حول
يصفوا على حق وحصل على احكام لكن ما قدرش
ينافس واحد عشر سنه مشاعره في نفذ الحكم
في كل الاحوال انه يحكي القصه كثير انا
عايش القصه وطرحت في زين سؤالي القصه كده
يعني لي واحد عنده احكام ولا استطيع ان
منفذها فقدت السؤال وطرحت على واحد من
اساتذتنا البارزين في القانون وهو الاستاذ
الدكتور علي
واعتقد ان هو الديني راي فني يقولى ايه
السابق راي ثاني لكن
القصه لها ولا حكايه مرتبطه بعدم احترام
القانون وان القصه عدم احترام القانوني
سبب سياسي
وعاديه قصه لطيفه جدا انه بعد ثوره 52
1952 الثوره حصلت من الضباط الاحرار في
ثلاثه وعشرين يوليو سنه ثلاثه وخمسه اثنين
وخمسين بعدها سبعه ايام واجه الضباط
الاحرار وكلهم من حديث العقد بالسلطه ناس
شباب فريق يعني عنده رغبه لكن يعني ما
عندوش خبره بالسلطه وبعد سبعه ايام انه في
ازمه الازمه انه هم بعدما عزلوا الملك
فاروق
عليهما يسيروا في اجراءات تعيين تعيين
الاوصياء للملك البيبي الصغير احمد فؤاد
عشان يعينوا اوصياء على الملك ان مصر كانت
ليست ملكا بعد قيام الثوره قبل ما تتحول
الى جمهوريه عليهم وفقا للقانون سنه
1923 دعوه البرلمان المرحله البرلمان
المصري كان من حل حل الملك فاروق بعد حريق
القاهره الشهير في عنايه لسنه 52 تبقى
المشكله المشكله ان الضباط الاحرار مش
عاوزين دعوه البرلمان المنحل لانه ذات
الاغلبيه فيه لحزب الوفد مهما كان حزب
الوفد
التخريج قدمها لهم
فقيه دستوري وهو الفقيه الدكتور عبد
الرازق السنهوري والقصه كالاتي انه على
شيء
بالدستور بيقول انه في حاله غياب الملك
للمرض او الوفاه يجب دعوه البرلمان حتى
ولو كان من حلا علشان هو يرتب لاجراءات
الوسط او للبديل
وطرحوا الفكره على مجلس الدوله ومجلس
الدوله وقتها كان في عدد من العلماء كان
ابرزهم الفقهاء الدكتور وحيد رافه
والدكتور عبد الرازق السنهوري والشرطه في
وضع كثير من دساتير العالم العربي اللي
حضراتكم اه يعني في دول عربيه مختلفه
دكتور وحيد
قال ان المقصد انه في حاله غياب الملك
يبقى يجب دعوه الدستور المرحله والدستور
لم ينص صحيح على انه في حاله عزله لانه من
غير المنطقي انه دستور ملكي ينص على عمليه
اه يعني التنظيم انتقال السلطه عن طريق
الكلام على الملك لكن المنطق يقول انه
نتيجه اتحاد العله انه غياب الملك للمرض
للوفاء ايضا للعزل ال ال الدكتور عبد
الرازق السنهوري اللي بيكره حزب الوفد ولا
يرغب في عوده برلمان احنا يجب ان نلتزم ب
نص الدستور الدستور ال المرض والوفاه
واحنا حلقتنا فيها ف اه وبالتالي قدمت
خريجه مريحه جدا للضباط الاحرار وجهه نظر
الدكتور اه على الغتيت التي كانت بدايه
ماساه كبيره
ادت الى ان الضباط القادمين الجدد للسلطه
يدركها المحترم القوانين مش مهم لانه يمكن
ان تلعب فيها
وانه اي قانون اما ان احنا ممكن ان سنو
نجيب احد بقيه
او دستوري او كذا وممكن هو سن القانون
اللي احنا عاوزين او انه اه احنا نفسر
القانون
الى هنا انتهى الكلام
الدكتور علي الجديد اللي هو شيء بدي ادى
الى فوضى قوانين وت رساله من القوانين
المطارده اللي ادت في النهايه انت تاخذ
حكمه ما تعرفشي تنفذها لانه في القانون
والقانون المعارضه رساله كبيره جدا من
القبرين تؤدي الى ان الناس لا تحصل على
حقوق ات وتشعر بالظلم وتخشى من الذهاب الى
المحكمه لان الذهاب الى المحكمه يعني انت
موته يبقى ايام الورثه الى هنا انتهى كلام
الدكتور علي انا بقول لي القصه دي بقول
انه عدم احترام القانون اللي الان بيسعوا
ليه اه
تخريجات او اهداف مختلفه من شان انه عم
الشعور اللي موجود في مصر على مدار سبعين
سنه من عدم احترام القوانين
وبالتالي يزيد الماساه اللي موجوده في مصر
بالفعل في تحركات يعني يعني اذا كان ولابد
المؤيدين مراقبين انه الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السياسيه استمر ممكن يبدؤوا الحلول اللي
اقترحها اخرين الرئيسي يكون حزب السياسي
وان الحزب السياسي دائم تولي افكاره
ويدافع عن مشاريعهم يمكن ان هو يجد مرشح
اخر والمرشح الاخر دوت يتبنى اكمال
المشروعات اللي بداها الرئيس ولا اعتقد
انه الدستور بنص الجديد يمنع من الرئيس
يترشح مره اخرى بعد الفتره الاربع سنوات
التاليه
بيكون افضل كثير للرئيس افضل كثيرا هم من
الرئيس ارض الكثير الى مصر في تقديري
المتواضع الاخيره قبل ما قدر مساله
الدستور
الناس اللي هي مصره على انه الرئيس يجب ان
يستمر حتى يقتل ما كل الاحترام
ورده اي حد يحاول يتذكر لو كان سنه يسمح
او كندي تابع تذكر سبعين سنه منذ قيام
اثنين وخمسين والرئيس عبد الناصر يعني منذ
قيام الجمهوريه بكل رئيس كان فيه مجموعه
مصره انه الرئيس يبقى اذا كان ناجحا او
فاشلا اذا كان منتصرا او مهزوما انه يظل
يظل في السلطه يعني الرئيس السادات اصر في
دستور واحد وسبعين بعد ما عمل دستور واحد
وسبعين بعد اجراءات ما يقول سماعه ثوره
مايو انه مادتين وقلنا مشاكل ثلاثه
وثمانين نقدم مجموعه من النواب يا ريس
لازم تبقى نعمل تعديلات دستوريه تدقيق في
السلطه وتم اجراء تعديلات دستوريه
وبالمناسبه تغيير تغيير الدستور مادتين
الى مدد ومعاهم جمع اخرى من القوانين
استحداث مجلس الشوره اللي التعديلات
الجديده التي حاولت ستحدث
وبقي الرئيس ال وبعد كده طبعا تم اغتيال
الرئيس السادات وجاء الرئيس مبارك وعشرين
سنه في كل مره لما طرح تغيير الدستور سنه
الفين وسبعه وقال انه يعني صار
الحديث ان الرئيس مبارك يكفي عليه واكتفى
والوقت يعني يعني لا يجد اولا يترشح ل مدن
جديده كان الكلام ان الرئيس مبارك يجب ان
يستمر ليكمل ما بداه من مسيره كان دائما
بيتكلم الاستقرار والتنميه
الاقرب من كده ان الرئيس جمال عبد الناصر
بعد هزيمه سبعه وستين لما خرجوا يقول
الناس انها خرجت جموع الناس عشان تقولوا
يجب ان تبقى حتى تكمل ما بدات و تعيد بناء
القوات المسلحه بعد خساره الحرب واه
تخرجنا من المازق اللي احنا دخلنا يعني
تكمل سواء كنت حازما او كنت سواء كنت
منتصرا او خاسرا
القصه دي نخبه مستفيده تدافع عن فكره ولا
هو في ناس مقتنع كده فعلا وان تفسيرها ما
احتاجه الحقيقه تفسير
من قبيل مثلا استوكهولم سندروم او متلازمه
ا ستكون انه الاسير المخطوف من كثره بقاءه
تحت سلطه الدوله معينه او حكومه معينه
نتعاطف معها ولا لها ايه التفسير في كل
الاحوال كامل الاحترام المؤيدين للفكره
كامل الاحترام
الرافدين للفكره انا عرضت وجهتين نظر
وعرضت وجهه نظري الان اعاده لا اعرضها
واشكركم ولا اخر
[موسيقى]